you know I've heard that nicknames are a
big thing in Thailand is that true yes
let no why why are nicknames so big I
think it's because we want to be
westernized a little bit and we want to
have nicknames so in Thailand we have
our real names and our last names
um those are for you know government
like all these official
um documents but in real life day to day
we have nicknames and it's not it has no
relation to our real name whatsoever
okay so you will see a lot of weird
names like there's a lot of boat
what's up phone book yeah hey phone book
I just look around the house hey
chiffaro give you the nickname of
whatever they see yes my sister's name
is oil
why what you call her oil yes
um I thought yeah but you don't know why
you don't need it's just because it's an
it's an English word purple or Thai name
I think it's a popular tiny I have no um
I have no clue what's the weirdest name
what's the weirdest nickname you have in
Thailand that would be misinterpreted
here in the United States
um name yeah is there a nickname that no
no name is a name
oh my God that's fantastic because I'm
always forgetting people's names yeah
and if I was in town they'd be like hey
uh name that's pretty good it cuts out
the middle man yeah I love that yeah
it's my friend and he has a twin and his
twin name is nam which means name and
Thai okay so his name is
there's a lot of um names with the word
porn in the name because it's a bless it
means blessing like well listen it does
yeah porn has been quite a blessing for
us as well I'm sorry yeah wait so porn
means blessing so there are lots of
names that have
porn in it is there essentially someone
named porn oil no thank God no yeah yeah
but there's names like pornhitter
okay uh I see now why your mother is in
such a bad mood
you're always bringing oil porn boat and
arm to the house God knows what you
people are up to
um I don't blame your mom for being a
little cranky uh I have a question it
must be agreed to so many
misunderstandings in Thailand can't you
imagine the Mr Roper of Thailand
listening at the door
oh porn oil more porn oil and it's just
two friends playing chess but God knows
what Mr Roper thinks